warte ich bin noch gar nicht da hat
jetzt nur hallo hallo herr schmidt
übrigens richtig scheiße herzlich
willkommen waren ein video ja welche ich
hoffe euch geht es gut auch meine haare
sitzen über brauche es ist das hier
ich glaube dass mittlerweile ja auch gar
nicht mehr ob ich noch dreckiger wir
hätten oder halt nicht naja so leute auf
jeden fall was geht habe ich auf euch
geht es gut
hallo ihr habt hier wahrscheinlich am
titel auch schon gelesen auf jeden fall
steht jetzt was cooles an ich bin
nämlich so vor drei tagen und köln auch
durch den macd rad gefahren und hab dann
kürzlich gesehen das eis von der lok ist
es ja schon draußen ich weiß nicht ob
ihr das alle mitbekommen habt aber die
beiden haben ein eis rausgebracht und
ich bin jetzt um ehrlich zu sein mal
sehr gespannt ob es das auch einfach
hier war max gibt ich wollte nicht vor
drei tagen schon kaufen weil ich mir
gedacht habe das kann es eigentlich mal
ausprobieren und sagen mir schmeckt also
jungs mal sehen was ihr da gibt's erholt
habt die fans erst mal los
[Musik]
da
warte ich bin noch gar nicht da
hallo ich hätte gern happy meal einmal
cheeseburger und pommes und ketchup und
cola und resistance und dazu kommt dann
noch das crazy pop mit flori zwei mal zu
mal sonderaufwand hierdurch zu fahren
weil das auto so lange
[Musik]
wenn ich mir das so angucke kurze fragen
wollt ihr mich verarschen ich wollte die
originalverpackung haben dazu ohne spaß
soll das jetzt richtig schon wieder auf
ihr seid jetzt mann mein video also
mcdonald's meine ernsthafte frage
schaut euch mal die verpackungen
eigentlich müsste das so aussehen also
mehr rechte seien richter ist da schon
ziemlich enttäuscht was ich auch noch
kurz sagen was ihr habt ihr alle gehört
was habe ich bestellt
und was ist mit los was was soll ich
damit also ich bin wirklich meistens top
zufrieden mit macdonald aber heute
überhaupt nicht so leute was geht ab wir
haben jetzt bereits schon den nächsten
morgen ich habe jetzt so geholt habe
gegessen und ich war dann so müde den
schlaf gegangen habe das vorher noch so
gerade in die kühltruhe gesteckt und
hätte ich als neues kaufen müssen auf
jeden fall machen wir denn jetzt den
geschmackstest es regnet einfach nur in
deutschland und ich muss mir auch ein
bisschen beeilen weil ich musste meinen
koffer packen weil ich vielleicht nach
london in london war ich auch noch nie
hier haben wir die beiden ice die
sim-karte vielleicht am auftauen
ich kann jemand kurz aufmachen also ich
muss sagen optisch gesehen auch wenn die
verpackung jetzt nicht original ist
finde ich immer noch scheiße sieht es
auf jeden fall ganz gut aus und was ich
immer wichtig finde ist dass die in den
macquarie oder in den mc sunday wirklich
dieses flavour reintun weil wenn er
jetzt viel zu wenig drin ist kann es
auch gleich oder alles bestellt sofort
lernt also geschmack ist wichtig das
wurde aber auf jeden fall ganz gut
gelöst ich würde sagen ein bisschen
müssen wir noch warten
und das kommt über ein trugschluss
einfach überdreht
und die werbung hugo boss schneller auf
muss auf 7
dort dann ständig einstellung so leute
also ich habe es gerade noch zwei andere
gäste die auch probieren werden und zwar
einmal mein bruder hat und der christ
halb so leute erster geschmack ich bin
gespannt wie kannst du bei alter chris
brown schrieb vor dieser ganzen wie
nennt man das auf jeden fall dieses
dressing oder flavour das schmeckt sehr
süß und das christa halt brutal aber
wohl der trainer schmeckt aber ich
möchte auf jeden fall ganz gut fertig
wo wir so mein bruder probiert jetzt
was sagst du vielleicht irgendwie was
schmeckt gut an in welchen geschmack von
diesem komischen nicht zu orten von 1
bis 6 was sagst du nein schule in runde
zwei ok es auch probieren da hast du
meinst aber erstmal noch mal will aber
diese küche erinnern leicht und ist
kaktus aber er stimmt war 16 habe ich
zwar zwei sehr gut dann haben wir jetzt
drei meinung ich glaube bereich heißt
für mich ihr könnt jetzt wieder gehen
die leute kommt mal kurz mit
so kann man seine frau wie auch essen ja
leute also alles in allem muss ich erst
mal sagen es ist ein echt leckeres eis
schmidt übrigens richtig scheiße
dankeschön an sich ist echt lecker ich
finds richtig lecker vom dieses tracing
pop auf der zunge des britischen richtig
schön also wenn ihr mal bei michael
seith holt euch probiert ihr könnt ja
meine kommentare schreiben ob es schon
probiert habe also schöne grüße habt ihr
gut gemacht ich find's lecker kann man
auf jeden fall essen und ist vielleicht
was neues ich hoffe dass wieder
aufgefallen dass auf jeden fall noch
nach oben da und wir sehen uns morgen
oder übermorgen wieder haut rein